AI FARMS:
AI is ruining YouTube.
Gone are the days of genuine creators, pouring
their hearts into their videos, sharing their
vulnerabilities, and forming a deep connection
with their audience.
I’m not talking about cases in which creators
us AI to make better content.
I’m talking about videos like this and this
and this, content that’s completely generated
using AI from beginning to end.
Of course, this is most common within the
video essay space but all niches from sports
compilations and TV show predictions to tech
news and financial news have seen a rise in
AI generated content.
On one hand, it’s insane that such content
can be created completely using AI.
Everything from the idea generation, script
writing, and pacing to the voiceover, editing,
and thumbnail.
But on the other hand, this completely defeats
the entire purpose of YouTube.
The core to YouTube’s success was not about
high-budget productions like MrBeast or a
bunch of music videos from popular singers
or flashy displays, it was always the authenticity
that stirred millions of hearts and minds.
From heart wrenching geometry dash meltdowns
that are too relatable to creators opening
up and sharing their insecurities and worst
moments.
This has always been the magic of not just
YouTube but all forms of media, even traditional
TV.
How many people watch something just because
they love a specific character or hate a specific
character.
These stories and emotions filled with creativity,
diversity, and genuine human connection are
what make visual communication so engaging,
so compelling.
These AI farms of course try to replicate
this by telling ChatGPT to write stories in
a three act structure or by discussing big
well known people but you can usually immediately
tell when a video is made using AI, atleast
so far.
Sometimes, it’s as obvious as the voice
being a robot.
Othertimes, it’s a much more subtle feeling
that everything that you’re watching is
the exact same thing, like a broken record.
These automation channels have become masters
of clickbait and manipulating the algorithm,
saturating our feeds with low-quality content.
They found a formula, and they stick to it
relentlessly.
You’ll sometimes even see videos with the
exact same titles and thumbnails, the same
recycled footage, and even the same pacing
and story.
But whatever gives it away, it’s the same
distant feeling.
Is this why 2.5 billion people decided to
watch YouTube?
To see robots recap random movies that we’ve
never heard of?
Or was it to experience something?
The high of conquering an impossible level,
the wonder of traveling, and the pure joy
of passionately uniting around a niche topic.
These are the sparks that ignited YouTube’s
flame in the first place, bringing together
billions of people worldwide and it’s these
same sparks that AI is extinguishing from
the platform.
But there’s an even darker side to AI content.
Like with any gold rush, the people who are
actually profiting are the ones selling the
shovels as thousands of creators are being
sold the idea that they too can make a million
dollars a year posting such content.
So, join me as we uncover the dark side of
AI-generated content and its impact on the
authenticity that once defined this platform.
TOP 10 VIDEOS:
Completely AI generated content is very much
a new phenomenon.
ChatGPT hasn’t even been around for a year
at this point.
But unlike AI content itself, the distant
feeling associated with this content isn’t
new.
This distant feeling can attributed to YouTube
automation which can actually be dated back
to almost the beginning of YouTube itself
to January 25, 2007.
This was the day that one of the most iconic
channels of all time was created: WatchMojo.com.
These guys are now known as the OG content
farm but they didn’t start off that way.
In fact, for the first many years, they were
just posting simple tutorials and streetside
interviews.
Some of these videos did get tens of thousands
of views but most didn’t do so great.
In fact, many of them haven’t even crossed
the thousand view mark after 15 years.
Clearly, this wasn’t working, so WatchMojo
shifted to making translation content.
We’re talking Japanese translations, Hebrew
translations, Arabic translations, Russian
translations, and then there was the random
yoga videos as well.
These videos got much more consistent views
but it wasn’t till September 18, 2010 that
WatchMojo really cracked the code with the
video: top 10 Julia Roberts Movies.
This got just under a million views but then
WatchMojo went back to their classic content.
Fall fashion from in wear, 332 views.
Fashion Show: fall trends, 245 views.
But then they posted, Top 10 Will Smith Movies,
2.7 million views.
And then, they did it again, and again, and
again, and again, and again.
Each and every one of these videos were pulling
in hundreds of thousand if not millions of
views.
And before you knew it, WatchMojo would become
a full on top 10 channel putting out thousands
upon thousands of these videos, dozens of
which garnered tens of millions of views.
I was one of these hundreds of millions of
viewers back in the day but looking back,
I couldn’t tell you what exactly made these
videos so popular.
Many of these lists wouldn’t even take an
hour to compile and all of the footage you
needed was already out there.
So, there was nothing particularly special
about these videos but at the same time, there
clearly was.
Maybe, it was fans of Will Smith and Angelina
Jolie and all of these other topics wanting
to congregate and reminisce about their favorite
actor or singers’ best and worst moments.
Or maybe, it was just plain curiosity.
What actually are Bruce Lee’s top 10 moments?
Whatever the reason though, these videos were
some of the most popular in the world back
in the early and mid 2010s.
As such, we saw dozens and dozens of copycat
channels pop up like TheRichest, MostAmazingTop10,
Looper, TopTrending, Alux.com, Mr. Luxury,
and so many more.
All of them were basically just content farms.
They would outsource the entire video production
process from scripting and voiceovers to editing
and thumbnail design.
They didn’t have the help of AI back in
the day but these videos were basically indiscernible
from modern AI videos.
The goal wasn’t to tell a story or to convey
a message or to make a change.
The goal was to just create mindless entertainment
by focusing on quantity, quantity, quantity.
2, 3, 4, 5, uploads every single day, an upload
every few hours.
Most of these videos would do alright, some
would do bad, but a select few, these would
go viral making the entire operation worth
it.
But, almost as quickly as these channels rose
to fame, they fell off a cliff.
Taking a look at WatchMojo today, while they
do have 25 million subscribers, their recent
videos don’t get anymore views than their
2008 and 9 videos.
It’s even worse with TheRichest as many
of their videos struggle to even cross the
10k mark despite having 15 million subscribers.
Some of these channels have even stopped posting
altogether.
It was official.
The days of milking top 10 videos had come
to an end but this was just in time for a
new style of automation to take off.
ANIMATED VIDEOS:
On July 9, 2013, over 6 years after WatchMojo
was created, we would see a new channel enter
the space with a rather hard name: Kurzgesagt.
Kurzgesagt was by no means a content farm.
In fact, they were and still are the exact
opposite only posting once maybe twice a month.
Their goal with each video was to break down
the most complex topics you can think of in
the most elegant ways possible using beautiful
animations.
Kurzgesagt was truly a passionate team of
illustrators, animators, writers, researchers,
and music producers wanting to create the
absolute best content on the platform.
And this showed, it shined right through.
Over the past 10 years, they’ve only posted
a 193 videos but almost all of these videos
have tens of millions of views each.
Seeing this, it wasn't long until copycats
started entering the scene.
Likely the most infamous of which being the
Infographics Show.
I don’t wanna bag on the Infographics Show
too much as they do post some bangers from
time to time like how El Chapo escaped from
prison or how Ted Bundy was caught.
Also, they’ve actually been around longer
than Kurzgesagt being founded in 2011.
But, with that being said, they very much
operate like a content farm given that they
post 2 to 3 videos every single day.
Also, their animations and sound design aren’t
unique and inspired with each upload like
Kurzgesagt.
Rather, they just use a bunch of templates
and premade animations.
But, the soullessness of the Infographics
Show was nothing in comparison to what we
saw on November 15, 2016.
This was the fateful day that 5 minute crafts
was launched.
If you’ve already erased this channel from
your brain, let me give you a warning as I’m
about to give you a painful refresher of their
content.
Yeah, I think that’s all that needs to be
shown.
Originally, I was gonna show more examples
but I don’t want to be responsible for causing
brain damage so we’ll leave it there.
Seriously though, I don’t think you could
get a single person in the entire world to
argue that 5 Minute Crafts actually makes
good content but man are their videos so clickable.
16 FUNNY HACKS THAT WORK MAGIC. 21 SIMPLE
LIFE HACKS TO LOOK STUNNING EVERY DAY. 5-Minute
Crafts compilation: This video is a treasure
trove!
This was their strategy.
They were never trying to make content that
moves us or something.
Their goal was really just to get us to click
in an era where clickbait on YouTube worked
extremely well.
A couple months after 5 minute crafts popped
up, we saw another such channel pop up: Bright
Side.
Bright Side was really just a whole lot more
of the same thing which is not that surprising
when you consider that it’s owned by the
same parent company: The Soul Publishing.
The Soul Publishing also owns 123 GO!, Slick
Slime Sam, 5 year crafts, La La life, Actually
Happened and so many more.
These guys are literally the definition of
a content farm.
Across all their channels, they post like
50 videos every single day across 21 languages.
And for the longest time, this was working
phenomenally.
In fact, the parent company is the largest
YouTube corporation on the planet with over
1.2 billion subscribers on YouTube alone.
But, more recently, things aren’t looking
all that great.
While 5 minute crafts has 80 million subscribers,
many of their recent upload don’t even cross
100,000 views.
It’s even worse at Bright Side where many
of their uploads don’t even cross 10,000
views despite having 44 million subscribers.
The Infographics Show is fairing a lot better
but they too have fallen substantially from
their peak a couple years ago.
You know who hasn’t fallen off though?
Kurzgesagt.
To this day, they still put out the best videos
they can and they still get millions of views
on each and every video.
So, clearly, the demand for this content is
still stronger than ever but trying to mass
produce these videos and sensationalize them
didn’t work out for these copycats over
the long term but what if you added in the
help of AI?
AI VIDEOS:
The release of ChatGPT definitely lowered
the barrier for YouTube automation substantially.
Instead of paying a script writer a few hundred
dollars, you could just get AI to write a
script for free.
But, it wasn’t the ease itself that has
led to an explosion in AI content.
Rather, I believe the explosion can be attributed
to YouTube gurus.
Since the beginning of this year, we’ve
seen a massive influx in the number YouTube
gurus selling the idea of getting rich by
creating an automated AI YouTube channel.
They claim that they were able to make $30,000
within 30 days or a million within a year
and that you can too.
All you have to do is sign up for their “Free”
webinar.
To be honest, these website look exactly like
one of those Tai Lopez webinars.
They even have the timer for crying out loud.
Now, let me say, there is some legitimacy
to this as there is with all get rich quick
schemes.
Is it possible to get rich with with an automated
YouTube channel.
Sure.
Is it probable?
Of course not.
It’s just like dropshipping or Amazon FBA
or stock trading.
Possible yes, probable no.
And just like the Amazon FBA gurus led to
Amazon being flooded with garbage from Alibaba,
the YouTube automation gurus are leading to
YouTube being flooded with AI garbage.
At this point you can go to basically any
niche you want and you’ll find the same
videos with the classic robot voice, the sterile
scripts, and the collage of stock footage.
Now, I’ve got nothing against these creators.
If you’ve made this work, that’s awesome!
But that’s not the type of content that
I want to be associated with nor is that the
direction that I want to see YouTube head
in.
And that’s why we’re talking face to face
here for the first time in 4 years.
Also, none of this is to say that I’m against
creators using AI.
AI is a phenomenal tool that absolutely should
be leveraged to make the entire production
process more efficient and to put out the
best content possible.
AI, however, should not be used to make low
quality spam to milk views.
Drop a like if you agree.
Fortunately, I don’t think AI garbage is
here to stay.
It’s a pretty new trend so I don’t expect
it to disappear immedietely.
In fact, it could very well gain momentum
over the next 2, 3, 4 years.
But zooming out to 5 or 10 years, I think
we’ll look back at this time period and
the AI spam the same way that we look back
on vlogs, pranks, top 10 channels, and Bright
Side.
The bottomline is that people come here for
authenticity and relatibility.
When AI adds to that?
Perfect.
When AI takes away from that though, well,
I think that content can only go so far but
that’s just what I think.
I would also argue that there is a sponsorship
problem on YouTube.
Check out this video to learn more.